nielsen
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a los observadores de
france 24 esta semana dos de nuestros
colaboradores en turquía y rusia nos
alertaron sobre los problemas de
contaminación del agua en sus
respectivos países luego veremos la
verificación de la semana con una
noticia falsa que está relacionada con
la vacunación contra el cubil 19 en
canadá
es un fenómeno que ha empeorado desde el
comienzo de la primavera el mar de
mármara en turquía está cubierto de
mucílago una espuma viscosa segregada
por microorganismos marinos también
conocida como moco marino
el fenómeno está relacionado tanto con
la contaminación como con el
calentamiento global y preocupa a la
población
nuestro observador pudo grabar estas
impresionantes imágenes
creo que fue el 5 de mayo fui a la
marina de grisel en udalla provincia de
bursa en turquía 60 en un barco y trate
de alcanzar la superficie con mis pies
como se puede ver en el vídeo intenté
romper esa capa con mis pies empezó a
leer mal a algas podridas o algo así y
creo que eso siguió en la marina durante
10 o 15 días y volvía el fin de semana
pasado vi que el mar estaba verde y no
podía ver más de 5 centímetros hacia
abajo la semana pasada salí a navegar
y vi que todavía había grandes bandas de
música o en el mar según varios
científicos turcos el fenómeno estaría
vinculado a la descarga muy frecuente de
aguas residuales directamente en el mar
así como al uso intensivo de detergentes
durante la pandemia alcohol 19 para
tomar mucho tiempo tal vez meses para
deshacernos del mucílago todos tememos
que afecte nuestras vidas y más después
de la pandemia
si seguimos contaminando el mar de
mármara de esta manera durante los
próximos 10 años creo que no habrá nada
de vida bajo el agua
[Aplausos]
no es jon produce
una segunda fuga de petróleo en un mes
los habitantes de la república de komi
en el noroeste de rusia ya no soportan
los repetidos derrames de petróleo el 11
de mayo ya se había producido una fuga
100 toneladas de hidrocarburos se habían
derramado entonces en un sólido ductos
de la compañía petrolera lukoil una
parte en el río huerva ekaterina
bychkova es representante electa del
consejo regional el 26 de mayo descubrió
una fuga de agua salada contaminada
procedente de un pozo de petróleo cerca
de su pueblo no beatbox
el 26 de mayo volvía del río con la
hípica una extraña mezcla corría por un
arroyo
luego intentamos encontrar el origen de
la fuga y lo logramos
era el pozo petrolero 447 del yacimiento
del zinc
la primera catástrofe grave se produjo
en 1994 hubo un gran derrame de petróleo
desde ese incidente la naturaleza fue
destruida las enfermedades cambiaron la
agricultura desapareció porque tenemos
estas filtraciones porque nuestros
oleoductos me parece no cumplen ninguna
norma la gente está tan acostumbrada a
ver petróleo en el agua que a veces
piensa que no tiene sentido luchar
contra eso no creo que sea el caso lo
importante es evitar que se repita
[Música]
la compañía petrolera lukoil dijo en un
comunicado que la fuga del 26 de mayo
fue causada por un fenómeno natural y
que no era tóxica una explicación poco
convincente para el comité de rescate de
pechora que envió las muestras al
laboratorio para su análisis
[Música]
en canadá a los niños de 12 a 15 años
pueden recibir la vacuna de facer contra
kobe 19 a partir del 5 de mayo pero la
decisión causa ciertas controversias
estas imágenes fueron tomadas en toronto
el 23 de mayo frente a la alcaldía el
edificio se había convertido en un
centro de vacunación temporal por un día
ese día la campaña no estaba dirigida
sólo a los niños sino a todas las
personas mayores de 12 años por otra
parte es necesaria la autorización de
los padres para vacunar a los niños en
la provincia canadiense de ontario esta
cuestión está resuelta desde 1996 como
lo señala la alcaldía de toronto en su
página web de acuerdo con la legislación
provincial sobre el consentimiento para
la atención sanitaria no existe una edad
mínima para dar el consentimiento para
la vacunación es responsabilidad
profesional y legal de todo el personal
médico obtener el consentimiento
informado antes de la vacunación así que
si puede parecer sorprendente pero en
esta provincia un niño puede ser
vacunado sin la autorización de sus
padres por último en cuanto a la policía
no incidían intervención de los padres
sino que trataban de alejar a los
manifestantes que no tenían ningún
vínculo con los niños vacunados sus
peticiones iban más allá de la donación
de los niños había pancartas contra el
uso de mascarillas y frases que atacaban
las restricciones sanitarias como
hechos antes que el miedo al final tres
manifestantes fueron detenidos y 2500
personas fueron vacunadas en este sea
entre los 23 de mayo en resumen este
vídeo no muestra a los oficiales de
policía bloqueando a las personas cuyos
hijos están a punto de recibir una dosis
de la vacuna por otro lado aunque
resulte sorprendente es cierto que los
menores pueden ser vacunados en los
diarios sin autorización de sus padres
es todo por esta semana si usted quiere
ser uno de nuestros observadores puede
entrar en contacto con la producción del
programa nuestros datos de contacto los
encuentran en sus pantallas te esperamos
sus fotos y sus vídeos para conocer los
hechos que ocurren alrededor del mundo
desde el punto de vista de un periodista
aficionado hasta pronto
[Música]